hemos hecho muchos vídeos sobre la
elasticidad precio de la demanda ahora
nos centraremos en la elasticidad precio
de la oferta y es una idea muy similar
sólo que en esta ocasión se aplica a la
oferta es una medida de qué tan sensible
es nuestra cantidad ofrecida a cambios
porcentuales en el precio y lo
calcularemos como nuestro cambio
porcentual en la cantidad ofrecida ante
un cambio porcentual en el precio un
cambio porcentual en el precio ahora
para hacer esto un poco más tangible
veamos un mercado simple digamos que
este es el mercado de manzanas donde
nuestro eje vertical es el precio y esto
podría ser de miles de pesos por
tonelada y luego nuestro eje horizontal
es la cantidad que podría ser en
toneladas por día esta tabla de oferta y
esta curva de oferta describen
esencialmente los mismos datos
así que pensemos en nuestra elasticidad
precio de la oferta a medida que pasamos
del punto a
del punto a al punto b bueno en la tabla
de oferta el punto a es el punto que
tenemos aquí nuestro precio es 4 nuestra
cantidad es 1 y el punto b está justo
aquí entonces calculemos nuestra
elasticidad precio de la oferta del
punto a al punto b en primer lugar cuál
será nuestro cambio porcentual en el
precio bueno vamos de 4 a 6 por lo que
es un incremento de 2 de modo que
nuestro cambio porcentual en el precio
es igual a 2 es cuando aumentamos de una
base de 4 por 100 por ciento y esto por
supuesto va a ser igual a un aumento del
50% en el precio y entonces cuál será
nuestro porcentaje de cambio en la
cantidad bueno vamos de 1 a 2 así que
estamos iniciando en una base de 1
estamos aumentando en 1 y luego
multiplicamos eso por 100 % eso nos da
100 por ciento por lo tanto cuando
tenemos un aumento del 50% en el precio
esto resultó de ir del punto a al punto
b un aumento del 100% en la cantidad
ofrecida así que 100 dividido entre 50
es igual a 2 ahora qué pasa si vamos del
punto b al punto c este es el punto ce
pausa en el vídeo y traten de calcular
la elasticidad precio de la oferta
cuando vamos del punto b al punto c
bueno vamos a hacer un cálculo similar
nuestro cambio porcentual en el precio
comenzamos con una base de 6 y estamos
aumentando en 2 vamos a multiplicar eso
por 100 % eso es aproximadamente un
tercio por cien por ciento
aproximadamente es igual a 33.3 por
ciento y entonces cuál es nuestro cambio
porcentual en la cantidad ofrecida bueno
vamos a pasar de 2 a 3 entonces
comenzamos con una base de 2 aumentamos
en 1 y multiplicamos por 100% y esto va
a ser igual a 50% de modo que cuando
tenemos un aumento de 1
o un aumento del 33.3 de nuestro precio
tenemos un aumento del 50% de nuestra
cantidad ofrecida cuando pasamos del
punto b al punto c otra forma de pensar
en esto es dividir 50% entre un tercio
es lo mismo que 50% multiplicado por
tres y por lo tanto eso es igual a 1.5
tal como vimos cuando calculamos la
elasticidad precio de la demanda cuando
tienes una curva lineal como esta la
elasticidad precio puede cambiar a lo
largo de la curva recuerda no es lo
mismo que la pendiente ahora otra cosa
que debemos tener en cuenta es la forma
en que calculé la elasticidad precio de
la oferta en este vídeo que posiblemente
sea la forma más simple no obtendrías el
mismo valor cuando calculas la
elasticidad que va de aã ve que si lo
hicieras dv
hay técnicas ligeramente más avanzadas
por ejemplo la técnica del punto medio
que te dará la misma respuesta
independientemente de la dirección en la
que vayas pero eso no lo veremos en este
primer vídeo ahora tal como lo
analizamos en el caso de la demanda hay
casos donde considerarían una oferta más
inelástica y casos que considerarían una
oferta más elástica por lo tanto una
manera de pensar en esto es si la
magnitud de la elasticidad precio de la
oferta es menor que 1 y por supuesto
esta es la magnitud por lo que será
mayor o igual a 0 bueno entonces estamos
hablando de elasticidad precio de la
oferta inelástica inelástica esta es una
situación en la que nuestra cantidad
ofrecida no va a cambiar mucho no será
tan sensible a nuestro cambio en el
precio ahora si nuestra elasticidad
precio de la oferta es mayor que 1
generalmente se considera que es
elástica es decir para un cambio
porcentual en el precio
el cambio porcentual en la cantidad
ofrecida será mucho mayor hasta el
próximo vídeo